[Music]
it's an age-old saying good writers
borrow great writers steal you can
simply iterate on existing ideas or you
can study them understand them and make
them your own
of course the sentiment doesn't just
apply to writing it can be said about
any creative endeavor
including video games and in this regard
Call of Duty Black Ops for the latest in
the long-running yearly series has
stolen a lot and it is all the better
for it
leaving aside trite quotes black ops 4
is just a lot of fun in fact it's the
most fun I've had with any Call of Duty
since modern warfare 2 this caught me
off guard as an annual release Call of
Duty has felt stale for a while now
despite its trips back to World War 2
the dystopian future and the fringes of
outer space throw in the fact that
developer Treyarch didn't include a
single-player campaign this year and I
was all but turned off from the property
black ops 4 would be another entry in
the yearly ritual I had grown so tired
of I would log on play a few hours get
my fill and move on to the next triple-a
release or so I thought almost
immediately black ops 4 had me hooked
after four hours of multiplayer I
sincerely wanted to play more I wanted
to learn each specialist character I
wanted to find my main so to speak call
of duty has been inching closer to
becoming an actual hero shooter for
years now but in 2018 it's finally taken
the dive it's still very much Call of
Duty with a quick time to kill three
lane maps and an abundance of
progression options with which to outfit
your characters but it's also taken some
of the best parts of its hero shooter
contemporaries and made them its own
first and foremost are the heroes
themselves or in this case the
specialists in addition to the normal
creative class loadouts inherent to the
series each specialist has his or her
own unique gadget and weapon the gadgets
have a shorter cooldown and benefit you
in a variety of specialized scenarios
Ajax is nine bang for instance is great
for stunning enemies on a control point
serifs tactical deploy beacon on the
other hand gives your teammates an
alternate spawn point shortening the
distance to crucial objectives
specialist weapons function more like
ultimate abilities ruins grab slam can
clear an entire
of opponents while torques barricade
emits microwaves in a straight path in
recent iterations of the yearly
franchise character specific abilities
were a pretty minor the specialist in
black ops 3 had unique weapons and the
combat rigs of infinite warfare provided
additional perks but black ops 4 finds
ways to make your character selection
matter and to change how you play the
game the specialist recon who happens to
be my favorite relies on Intel and
positioning the character Nomad focuses
on traps and defensive skills if you're
not playing to each of their strengths
you might not be helping your team to
the full extent some of the most
successful multiplayer shooters today
make use of heroes overwatch and Rainbow
six siege are the first that come to
mind placing their rosters at the center
of their design
overwatch a superpowers feed into its
colorful bombastic gameplay while sieges
operator gadgets add even more
complexity to its high stakes rules the
thing that strikes me most about black
ops 4 is multiplayer is that I'm
constantly thinking throughout each
match Call of Duty games don't usually
encourage this the shooters have always
been aggressively decent allowing me to
go through the motions trading kills and
earning new weapons at a steady pace
black ops 4 however puts you at a
disadvantage if you don't make use of
your unique abilities on the flip side
more often than not it makes me feel as
if I'm actually earning my wins this
sentiment amplifies when you switch
between game modes defensive specialists
are crucial in defending control points
while Intel focused characters excel in
more punishing hardcore modes black ops
4 has borrowed something else from
overwatch and Rainbow six siege it's
storytelling focuses on backstory and
context allowing you to fill in the gaps
as you play each specialist has an intro
video along with dossiers that outline
their origins and career experience the
specialist HQ missions provide enough
story to make its characters memorable
without subtracting from the gameplay in
the process this focus on player driven
storytelling that is allowing players to
use context in the game systems
themselves to find their own stories has
become prevalent in recent years
overwatch has thrived on this kind of
narrative with tangential short videos
that add flavor to each character siege
even goes so far as to factor its
relationships into
it's gameplay the character Ecco is
immune to the Korean operator dhoka bees
hacking attack because they grew close
outside of combat and helped each other
improve their gadgets black ops 4
doesn't take things this far but I
wouldn't be surprised to see Treyarch
continually lean into its cast as the
game continues to grow it already has a
healthy roster of ten specialists and
I'm having a blast learning each one's
unique abilities time will tell if
there's longevity in this formula but
Treyarch already has a solid foundation
to build on of course for all of the
improvements that the
player-versus-player arena makes this is
only one third of the black ops 4
package and while the new zombies maps
are a joy and offer dozens of hours of
frantic cooperative play I want to turn
your attention to black out it's the
next in a growing number of battle
royale modes and one of the biggest
attractions for this year's Call of Duty
entry unless you avoided video games
social media or pop culture in general
for the past three years or so you're
probably familiar with the battle royale
formula 100 players drop onto a map
gather supplies and fight until they're
the last team or individual alive
blackout is just as straightforward as
you'd imagine it combines the structure
of a battle royale with the mechanics of
Call of Duty and it works it works
really well the tight controls and
comfortable aiming feel great on
blackouts map and a slightly longer time
to kill ensures that many will have a
fighting chance it also incorporates
zombies in a clever way certain areas of
the map are infested with a living dead
but also offer better loot for those
that brave the monsters it's a simple
risk reward system that adds character
to the map brings a unique wrinkle to
the battle royale formula and ties into
the overarching Call of Duty lore as was
the case with its PvP modes black ops 4
understands not just how to borrow from
other games but how to steal and in the
process make those elements even better
I have to hand it to Treyarch the team
clearly understands what makes Call of
Duty tick it could have implemented some
building mechanics a la fortnight or
gone completely overboard with the
number of zombies on its blackout map
but it held back black I was a simple
mode that works so well because it
simple it uses call of duty strengths to
make a seemingly obvious mode perform
extremely well it's ironic that Call of
Duty has expressed confidence in its own
identity
specifically by understanding the
identities of other games it recognizes
the value of the Battle Royale genre and
the practicality of hero shooters
storytelling and morphs them both into
something with their own distinct flavor
the result is a shot in the arm for one
of the most pervasive series in modern
games and that is no small
accomplishment
[Music]